Russian forces are edging closer to
capturing a key Ukrainian city after
days of fighting Street battles are
underway in the industrial Harper's
severo Donetsk in the Eastern donbass
region the governor there says that 80
of the city is now under Russian control
but in a boost for Ukraine Germany and
the United States announced additional
weapon support for Kiev
including Advanced rocket systems with a
range of up to 80 kilometers
that's when DW correspondent Rebecca
Ritter's who is in Kia for us Rebecca
what more can you tell us
they're moving pretty slowly we are
looking at a war of attrition at the
moment but as you say Russians making
small gains in that key City in lahance
severeign
the governor there the governor of that
region now saying that they do indeed
Russia has now around about 80 percent
of that city under its control we saw
one of the chemical plants there it is
an industrial city one chemical plant
was hit yesterday and we saw plumes of
toxic smoke we're now told that
civilians are trying to hide in that
factory but the governor's saying this
will not be an as of style too if you
will referring to that steel plant in
mariu pole that's now Infamous in this
battle on the other side of the river
several several Donetsk is a sister city
with Lizzy chance it's on the other side
of a river and the Russians are
struggling to get across that River
they're now trying a tactic of
bombarding it from another angle around
the other side of this City so that they
don't indeed have to cross that River
because that has been proven quite
difficult for them in the war so far
they haven't been very successful at
crossing rivers so we'll have to see
what happens there but yeah as you say
it is not looking like good for Ukraine
in luhanska Russia nearly taking all all
control of it now now the ukrainians say
they desperately need heavy weapons to
turn the tide do we know how long it
will take for to deploy for these
weapons that were promised by Germany
and the U.S
yes that announcement of weapons from
the U.S and Germany was very welcomed
here in Ukraine but of course it won't
be immediate we will see what we're
seeing at the moment carry on for some
weeks we're hearing that the Pentagon
estimate that these heavy weapons from
the U.S could take around three weeks to
arrive here of course ukrainians will
need to be trained on them as well and
there is we're hearing about delays
potentially from the German
anti-aircraft anti-defense systems that
have been promised that they're not not
going to come from stockpiles within the
German Army they're actually going to
come directly from the manufacturer so
that could add delays so not really sure
exactly of a time frame there we do know
that Ukraine desperately need them as
soon as possible we're hearing now that
UK the UK has also agreed to send some
of these longer range weapon systems and
are also going to be training the
ukrainians in how to use them as well so
we will see some uh some some benefit
from those weapons but not for some
weeks we don't know what's going to
happen in between then whether Ukraine
can hold back or whether Russia's just
going to keep storming ahead probably
the latter but definitely welcome news
that these weapon systems are on their
way
Rebecca Ritter is there reporting live
from Kiev thank you Rebecca
meanwhile Russia has accused the U.S of
deliberately escalating the war by
sending Advanced military aid to Ukraine
Russian foreign minister Sergey lavrov
warned that Western weapons deliveries
were raising the risk of other countries
being drawn into the conflict but U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken said
that Washington has assurances from Kiev
that Ukraine will not use these weapons
to strike targets inside Russia it's
great to see you again for more now
let's cross over to our military analyst
Frank lebwich who joins us from Oxford
in the UK frankly Russian foreign
Ministry there calling the Western
weapons deliveries a direct provocation
how seriously should we take These
Warnings
well Gohan the words used by lavrov were
a direct provocation the strong
implication was that the the provocation
was by Ukraine and he did say look it's
such risks exist of escalation and that
in one sense is no more than a statement
of fact but that's another way of
looking at this we've had this saber
rattling from the start of the war in in
February it's been we have it
occasionally every time a new weapons
delivery is announced which of course
reflects the the impact on the ground
that such reinforcements are having but
look it's not in Russia's interest to
take on the west
by contrast or on the other side let's
not forget what Biden said in his op-ed
at the I think it was on Monday he said
look as long as we our allies aren't
attacked U.S troops won't be going into
Ukraine and nor will we take on take on
Russia so look there's a were that to
take place that would signal the end of
the Russian Adventure in in Ukraine and
probably the end of the Russian armed
forces are going concern for quite some
time so there's two sides to this a line
is being walked and I think we should
treat this with the sort of mild
contempt it deserves at the moment okay
so talk to us now about this line that
the Western leaders are trading right
now enabling the ukrainians to fight
back without provoking Putin to the
extent that he will eventually retaliate
that's difficult isn't it
yes it is and the U.S particularly and
especially the U.S I come to the UK in a
second has taken break strong steps to
indicate that they've given I think back
Channel and indeed open uh uh orders to
the ukrainians it's the medium-range
weapons that they've delivered will not
be used against against Russia
interestingly I'll just say this in
passing the UK defense secretary Ben
Wallace about six weeks ago said that
well there's no reason why the Ukraine
shouldn't use UK weapons against Russia
although they were short-ranged very
unlikely to be used that way so look I
think yes the West is drawing its own uh
setting its own parameters of the
delivery of these weapons and this is a
this is an issue of sort of subtle
messaging I think between the two large
sides in this that's to say the west and
Russia with Ukraine caught in between
needless to say
now Frank Bowell estimates this war is
going to drag on for months at least um
at what point or will there be a point
where the West can no longer afford to
watch from the sidelines
not getting hot I'm reminded uh those of
us who will be told who may remember
Bosnia where this kind of behavior by
Russian forces egregious shelling of uh
civilian areas outright murder of
non-competents mass killings and so
forth the West stood by essentially had
a sense of strategic boredom I don't
sense that yet but uh let's not forget
that the ukrainians are fighting back
effectively and the West is involved but
this treading this line is difficult as
for and will remain Difficult by the way
I would say another thing we makes it's
conceivable we might see some form of
Russian retaliation not on the ground
against Western Force but possibly
another domain cyber or space but I put
that aside no look this war is going to
go on now till the end of this year it's
going to run into next year and possibly
Beyond as the ukrainians shape up to
counter-attack and maybe some months
before that even starts
our military analyst Frank ledwich there
thank you Frank
thank you gerhardt
as we've heard Russian forces are
keeping up their attacks on donbass in
eastern Ukraine pounding the area with
shells and artillery many people have
fled the region but our correspondent
Matthias Berlinger went to one Village
close to the front line to talk to the
volunteers and residents who are still
holding out there
when the war broke out hortitza
immediately registered as a volunteer
for Ukraine's territorial Defense Forces
now he's guarding this Village on the
front line in donpass
thank you it's really loud they shoot
from tanks they shoot anti-tank missiles
cannons I'm not a career officer so it
is difficult for me to distinguish all
of them by sound
his nickname is just one of around 100
000 volunteers who've joined units like
his since the beginning of the war many
are fighting for the first time
this is from a rocket
the village is just three kilometers
from the front line it's an important
defense position
the locals were suspicious of us in the
beginning they were watching us we were
patrolling the streets looking after the
place and they were hiding but as things
got worse here with electricity and food
we started to help out here and there
and slowly trust has been building
now soldiers and the remaining villagers
have got used to each other Russian
shells hit the village daily and they
hid randomly
is a veterinarian and a beekeeper
look it didn't get through better than
body armor
The Village used to be his getaway spot
now he plans to leave
my psyche is wrecked we hide all the
time from the shooting
look that's a new one it landed recently
poor bees they'll go crazy
we'll have honey with shrapnel this year
most of his neighbors have already left
still there are times when it's calm 62
year old Popeye another Battlefield name
uses the opportunity to study Ukrainian
I used to speak a mix of Ukrainian and
Russian but being a soldier in the
Ukrainian Army I can't be Russian
speaking that would be against my
principles now I am transitioning to
Ukrainian
not everybody wants to leave it is
because of his dog that 82 year old
Nicola evechenka says he is still here
he was injured by shrapnel the day
before
but he wants to stay
we'll live as long as the devil doesn't
come after us
McCullough has been working in Russia
for many years he says he has very few
Illusions about the fate of his village
there is no way to beat Russia but they
continue to do everything to make things
worse even for themselves I'm talking
about the leadership not the Ordinary
People ordinary Russians but the same
thing as everybody else a decent life
at least for today no shells have yet
landed nearby it is in the neighboring
Village that artillery has taken its
toll today
voters in Denmark have overwhelmingly
backed a referendum to join the European
Union's common defense policy more than
two-thirds voted yes in Wednesday's poll
on whether to abandon Denmark's
long-held position of opting out of
shared EU defense decisions
Russian aggression in Ukraine prompted
that landmark ballot
a pile of yes ballots just a handful of
no's Danish voters Cast Away Decades of
resistance to marching lockstep with the
European Union on matters of Defense a
decision once unlikely this year became
essential says Denmark's prime minister
meta friedrichsen
there was a Europe before February 24th
before the Russian invasion and there is
another Europe after
when threats to Liberty are on Europe's
door and there is once again war on our
continent then you can't be neutral
in three previous referendums Danes had
voted against closer EU alignment but
Russia's attack on Ukraine convinced
voters that cooperation is more
important than isolation in times of War
it's obviously important to to state if
you feel that you want to join this
community or not we should join because
you know otherwise he's just that one
friend who never buys around
the outcome means Danish troops can take
part when EU States put boots on the
ground in operations such as those held
in Mali and elsewhere and benefit from
joint weapons purchases
Denmark is the latest Nordic state to
reverse course on Military strategy its
previously neutral neighbors Sweden and
Finland have applied to join the NATO
military Alliance
for for small European States being
wholly integrated in the European
security architecture whether it be the
EU or NATO is increasingly important at
the moment Denmark's decision shows
Russia's attempts to divide the European
Union are bringing its countries closer
together
joining us now from Copenhagen is our
correspondent Barbara basil Barbara does
this decision mean Denmark is now
required to send troops to EU missions
or spend additional money on equipment
a girl had they are required but it
always is of course voluntary but there
are no slouches militarily so they just
recently sent troops to Estonia to
reinforce the eastern border so they
will probably uh participate in European
missions and they have already in just a
little while ago increased their defense
budget up to two percent which is the
the limit demanded in the amount
demanded by NATO models and it's a big
increase for a small country like this
so yes they're they're on board with
this but what's really remarkable about
it is this tremendous change in feeling
and and political atmosphere here in the
country because in the past they more or
less chronically said no to anything
that came from Europe but this time they
really have felt this is the time and
the situation where you have to step
inside the tent where it's better to be
together with others
now all Nordic countries have now
changed their previously independent or
even neutral military positions what
does that mean for the region
it means for the region that they can
work together more closely I mean these
are small countries they do have armies
professional armies so they can do
something but it is much better when
they do it together for instance they
can decide together who buys helicopters
who buys new ships they can do some
burden sharing and of course they feel
that if they really work together
closely all the naughty countries
together with the baltics for instance
they can bring some weight to the table
politically not only militarily but they
will have a voice they will be heard
amongst others about talking about
strategy and what to do against this
threat that everyone feels is coming
from the East is coming from from Russia
and this is such a huge change for these
countries for who for decades seem to
live in this sort of a paradise of
political Independence and being apart
from others they now have understood
very deeply and emotionally that they
just have to go together with everyone
in order to protect themselves
DW correspondent Barbara bezel reporting
from Copenhagen there thank you Barbara